¿Os habéis dado cuenta de qué América
Latina es desde el punto de vista político-social
una de las regiones más homogéneas de todo
el mundo?
En Latinoamérica la mayoría de los países
tienen el mismo idioma, la religión católica
es mayoritaria y casi todos tienen una historia
común, aunque sólo sea porque la mayoría
de ellos nacieron tras independizarse del
Imperio español.
Y en el caso de Brasil, con ciertos matices
propios, lógicamente, el camino pues viene
a ser en cierta forma muy similar.
Fijaos si no en la política: Latinoamérica
comparte una cultura de gobierno presidencialista,
con liderazgos que van de la derecha a la
izquierda pero que suelen tener muy frecuentemente
un ingrediente común: el populismo.
Así que en definitiva, en términos sociopolíticos
podemos decir que los países que integran
esta región son en el peor de los casos primos
hermanos.
Sin embargo, todos estos parecidos y todos
estos lazos tienen un límite muy claro: la
economía.
Sorprendentemente en el terreno económico
la región está muy poco integrada y la variedad
de políticas es enorme.
Desde la prudencia inquebrantable en el control
de las cuentas públicas de Perú, hasta el
comunismo de Cuba, pasando por el populismo
del blockchain en El Salvador o la adicción
al dinero del Banco Central del gobierno argentino.
Sin embargo, pese a todo, ¿sabíais que desde
hace décadas existen numerosos proyectos
para que Latinoamérica tenga ni más ni menos
que una moneda común?
¿Veremos nacer el euro latino?
Pues…
Atentos.
[Por cierto, importantísimo: si os gustan
los temas económicos no os podéis perder
nuestro canal hermano VisualEconomik.
En él os hablamos de temas tan interesantes
como el salario mínimo, cómo están funcionando
las sanciones contra Rusia o qué problemas
puede tener la dolarización de un país.
Si aún no lo conocéis echadle un vistazo
y decidnos qué os parece.
Ya somos más de 250.000 suscriptores.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción y al
final de este vídeo.
Dicho esto, continuemos.]
Queridos amigos, amigas, no creo que tenga
que conveceros de esta idea: la moneda es
un elemento esencial, clave, fundamental en
toda economía.
Claro que pese a ello no todos los estados
tienen su propia moneda.
En el mundo existen algunas “áreas monetarias”
que integran a más de un país.
La pertenencia a una de estas áreas monetarias
implica que los países miembros cedan una
parte de su soberanía y adopten una moneda
común, bien sea para el día a día o en
el caso más limitado para relacionarse comercialmente
entre los países miembros.
(Esto es algo que fundamentalmente puede producirse
de dos maneras distintas.
Primero, está el caso de las uniones formales
y pactadas, como ocurre por ejemplo en la
Unión Europea y el euro.
Y por otro está el caso de las uniones informales
que consiste en adoptar unilateralmente una
moneda extranjera.
Es decir, en este caso se cede la soberanía
monetaria a un tercer país cuyo banco central
sea percibido como más fiable.
Esto es, por ejemplo, el caso de países dolarizados
como Ecuador o Panamá.)
Sea cómo sea, no hablamos de procesos que
puedan desarrollarse de la noche a la mañana,
especialmente si hablamos de las uniones formales.
En este caso para que la cosa funcione tienen
que darse una serie de condiciones.
Estas condiciones, son más o menos las que
todos podemos imaginarnos: una tasa de inflación
baja, un déficit presupuestario controlado,
niveles de deuda ajustados y política de
tipos similares.
Ahora bien, no vamos a ponernos muy teóricos
con este tema.
Nos basta con saber que son a grandes rasgos
las áreas monetarias.
Y ahora que ya lo sabemos la pregunta es:
¿Qué tal fueron los experimentos latinoamericanos
para avanzar por este camino?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1 (CENTROAMÉRICA: UN PROYECTO PIONERO…
PERO ESTANCADO)
El 25 de febrero de 1964, Costa Rica, El Salvador,
Guatemala, Honduras y Nicaragua suscribieron
el conocido como «Acuerdo para el establecimiento
de la unión monetaria centroamericana».
Con este acuerdo estos países instaban a
sus respectivos bancos centrales a integrarse
en un “Sistema de Bancos Centrales Centroamericanos”,
que sería conducido por el Consejo Monetario
Centroamericano.
C1: (“... los mecanismos de cooperación
establecidos por los Bancos Centrales [...] señalan
la necesidad y la oportunidad de adoptar medidas
tendientes a realizar por etapas la integración
monetaria de Centroamérica” 4to punto del
Acuerdo para el establecimiento de la unión
monetaria centroamericana de 1964)
Pues a pesar de ser una iniciativa pionera
en la región, las guerras civiles centroamericanas
truncaron por completo este proyecto.
[Bueno, y de hecho sumergieron a estos países
en larguísimos procesos de violencia política,
como por ejemplo, entre otros, la revolución
sandinista en Nicaragua.]
No obstante, sin embargo, en 1974 se logró
un nuevo acuerdo monetario regional, un primer
paso que fue nuevamente modificado en los
90 para relanzar un Consejo Monetario común
encabezado por los presidentes de los bancos
centrales de Costa Rica, El Salvador, Guatemala,
Honduras y Nicaragua.
El objetivo de este órgano era fundamentalmente
asesorar a los diferentes gobiernos para avanzar
con las reformas que hacían falta para establecer
la tan ansiada moneda común.
C2: (“El Consejo promoverá la estrecha
coordinación y armonización de las políticas
monetarias con las políticas fiscales, de
integración y de desarrollo económico de
los países centroamericanos” Artículo
39 del Acuerdo Monetario Centroamericano de
1999)
Más tarde en el año 2002 se unió a este
acuerdo la República Dominicana, pero de
la moneda nunca más se supo y de hecho, por
ejemplo, el Salvador dolarizó su economía
en el año 2000.
Hoy este órgano con sede en San José, Costa
Rica, es básicamente un foro de diálogo.
Pero oye, tenemos que tener en cuenta que
fue un proyecto surgido en los años 60…
Fue una iniciativa realmente pionera.
Al menos que se lleve ese crédito.
(T2: EL SOCIALISMO DEL SIGLO XXI CONTRA LA
“DICTADURA DEL DÓLAR”)
Según cálculos de la Reserva Federal, entre
1999 y 2019 el dólar supuso el 96% de la
facturación comercial en el continente americano,
una zona donde ni el rublo ni el yuan ni el
euro ni ninguna otra moneda han podido desplazar
al papel moneda del Tio Sam.
Por supuesto esto no es algo malo.
Sin embargo, para los arquitectos del Socialismo
del Siglo XXI, esto no era sino la “dictadura
del dólar”.
Algo que, por supuesto, resultaba absolutamente
intolerable para el referente de este movimiento,
Hugo Chavez,quien se lanzó a toda una cruzada
contra el billete verde.
[A pesar de que en el terreno personal le
encantarán los billetes verdes.]
(“El imperio del dólar.
El mundo es víctima del Imperio del dólar
entre tantis.
Un día me dijo Fidel Castro: Chaves, mira,
Estados Unidos ha comprado Estados Unidos
ha comprado medio mundo con puros papeles.
Papeles que no tienen sustentación económica.
Pues llegó la hora [..] Nosotros tenemos
la idea y por primera vez la voy a comentar
en público, de una moneda internacional,
que a mi me emociona la sola idea: el Petro)
Pues bien, para ponerle fin a esta supuesta
“dictadura monetaria”, el chavismo tenía
en mente diferentes vías para eludir el uso
del dólar en sus transacciones comerciales.
Y finalmente en 2009 se optó por implementar
un Sistema Unitario de Compensación Regional,
generalmente nombrado por sus siglas: SUCRE,
en referencia al prócer independentista latinoamericano
Antonio José de Sucre.
N1 (Octubre de 2009: Venezuela y Bolivia estrenan
el Sucre: Ambos países estrenarán el nuevo
sistema de compensación de pagos creado el
pasado fin de semana por los países de la
ALBA.
El Universo)
Como nos dice su nombre, este mecanismo no
era una moneda en sí mismo, sino más bien
un sistema de pagos, donde se estableció
un tipo de cambio de 1,25 dólares por cada
SUCRE, algo que venía a desacoplar el uso
de la divisa norteamericana en las importaciones
y exportaciones de los países integrados
en este esquema.
Es decir, operaba mayoritariamente de manera
simbólica.
Pero técnicamente ya no operaban en dólares.
De esta forma, en la unidad de cuenta común
del Banco Central de cada país, no se registraba
el ingreso de dólares sino que se hacía
en Sucres, pese a que a su vez estos sucres
equivalían a una cierta cantidad de dólares
que, en definitiva, es lo que les daba valor.
[Lo sé, un galimatías…
Un tanto absurdo]
Inicialmente, este sistema fue implementado
por la Alianza Bolivariana para los miembros
del ALBA, una organización en la cual participan
Venezuela, Cuba, Bolivia, Ecuador y Nicaragua.
[Vamos, lo mejor de cada casa]
(“El Sucre es un sistema único de compensación
regional y eso comenzará siendo una moneda
virtual”)
Desde el año 2010, el aparato de propaganda
chavista difundió la idea del SUCRE a los
cuatro vientos.
Lo pintaban como un mecanismo ideal, que podría
dar lugar a una nueva moneda con la proyección
de sustituir el dólar en un plazo relativamente
corto de tiempo.
N2 (Septiembre 2011: Chávez llama a crear
moneda latinoamericana ante "dictadura del
dólar".
Cronista.)
Sin embargo, el mecanismo nunca logró desarrollarse
como moneda, y quedó estancado como un sistema
alternativo para sortear teatralmente el uso
del dólar, a pesar de que Hugo Chavez insistió
una y otra y otra vez hasta el hartazgo con
este tema:
(“El Sucre, algún día yo me imagino que
el Sucre será físico, Rafael, moneda física,
¿por qué no?
Hasta ahora es virtual pero yo quiero que
mi palabra, ojala, pueda incentivar [..] a
que juguemos duro con el Sucre.
No seamos mezquinos, es un mecanismo maravilloso.
Ustedes lo conocen.
Nos estamos liberando, ¿de qué?
De la dictadura del dólar a nivel internacional.”)
Por cierto, fue Rafael Correa - a quien acabamos
de ver junto a Chavez- quien condujo uno de
los países que más utilizó el SUCRE.
Entre los años 2011 y 2016, Ecuador ejecutó
al menos 6.319 transacciones mediante este
esquema, las cuales sumaron casi 3 mil millones
de dólares.
Y es que al parecer los políticos en este
país supieron darle un uso algo más “beneficioso”...
ATENTOS
C3: (“Lo que en un inicio se planteó como
un sistema multilateral de compensación de
pagos, en la realidad operó como un mecanismo
de exportaciones en su mayoría ficticias
y sobre valoradas en su mayoría de Ecuador
a Venezuela y que adicionalmente sirvió para
canalizar operaciones relacionadas con el
lavado de dinero, enriquecimiento ilícito
y peculado” FRAGMENTO DEL INFORME DE LA
COMISIÓN ESPECIALIZADA PERMANENTE DE FISCALIZACIÓN
Y CONTROL POLÍTICO¿Qué, cómo os habéis
quedado?
Seguro que esa no la esperábais.
El caso es que por este motivo, desde el año
2015, tanto justicia ecuatoriana como distintas
investigaciones del Legislativo de este país,
han identificado diferentes tramas de lavado
de activos mediante el uso del SUCRE.
El cual, por cierto, al final terminó como
casi todas las promesas del todopoderoso Socialismo
del Siglo XXI: entre expectativas a la deriva
y novedosas herramientas para ampliar la corrupción.
(T3 TIMIDEZ Y CAUTELA: EL MERCADO INTEGRADO
LATINOAMERICANO (MILA)
Antes de continuar, tenemos que hacer un breve
paréntesis: La integración económica en
Sudamérica tiene esencialmente dos caras:
una es el Mercado Común del Sur, el conocido
habitualmente como MERCOSUR - una organización
integrada por Argentina, Uruguay, Brasil,
Paraguay y Venezuela -aunque esta última
encuentra suspendida desde 2019-; y la otra
es la Alianza Pacífico, en la cual participan
Perú, Colombia, México y Chile.
Pues bien, es esta última la que en 2011
formó el Mercado Integrado Latinoamericano,
el conocido como MILA.
Este proyecto tampoco es una moneda en sí
misma, ni siquiera es un sistema de pagos.
En la Alianza Pacifico las cosas se están
tomando con mucha calma, y el primer paso
hacia una auténtica integración financiera
y económica se dio mediante esta iniciativa
donde no se unifican monedas, sino mercados
de capitales.
Pues bien, actualmente este proyecto reúne
a más de 700 compañías de este bloque económico,
representando un mercado que abarca el 41%
del PIB de América Latina y el Caribe y el
38% del total de los flujos de Inversión
Extranjera Directa en la zona.
Hay que decir que por el momento aquí no
existe ningún proyecto concreto de una Unión
Monetaria.
Pero la estabilidad de los miembros de la
Alianza y su mayor grado de apertura y libertad
económica - respecto por ejemplo, a los integrantes
de Mercosur - hacen que no parezca descabellado
que en un futuro no muy lejano los países
miembros puedan avanzar en esta dirección.
Pero, aún no hemos terminado.
Así que sigamos.
(T4 LAS APUESTAS MÁS RECIENTES: ENTRE EL
TANGO Y LA SAMBA)
En abril de 2019, se confirmó una reunión
entre el entonces Ministro de Economía argentino,
Nicolas Dujovne, y su par brasileño, Paulo
Guedes.
La reunión se celebró en Washington, en
medio de una agenda de citas con el FMI y
el Banco Mundial.
En aquel encuentro, ambos funcionarios hablaron
sobre el Peso Real: una moneda común gestionada
por Brasilia y Buenos Aires, a la cual podrían
llegar a sumarse los demás países del MERCOSUR.
(C4: “Tener una moneda común en toda Latinoamérica
sería muy bueno.
Creo que en 15 años, habrá cuatro o cinco
grandes monedas en el mundo.
En 15 años va a existir el dólar, el euro,
el renminbi chino, y ojalá allí esté el
‘peso real’ . Creo que vamos a desembocar
en una moneda común a futuro.”
Paulo Guedes, en julio de 2019.)
Sin embargo, meses después de esta atrevida
propuesta, Mauricio Macri fue derrotado en
las elecciones presidenciales y un nuevo gobierno
asumió el poder en Argentina.
El proyecto quedó por completo congelado…
Entre otras cosas porque Alberto Fernández
y Jair Bolsonaro no es que se llevaran particularmente
bien.
N3 (Bolsonaro y Fernández intercambian insultos
a pesar de la interdependencia de Brasil y
Argentina.
Merco Press)
Pero, un momento, porque así como unas elecciones
sacaron el tema de agenda en Argentina, otras
elecciones volvieron a traer la idea de una
moneda única, esta vez en Brasil.
ATENTOS
(T5: EL SUR: UNA MONEDA COMO PROMESA DE CAMPAÑA)
El banquero Gabriel Galípolo y el ex candidato
presidencial del Partido del Trabajo Fernando
Haddad - el cual, por cierto, fue derrotado
por Bolsonaro en 2018 - hicieron pública
la idea de crear el SUR, una moneda regional
que sería emitida por un Banco Central Sudamericano.
Este banco sería constituido mediante la
aportación de divisas por sus países miembros
en proporción a sus respectivas participaciones
en el comercio regional:
C5: (“La capitalización se haría con las
reservas internacionales de los países y/o
con un impuesto a las exportaciones de los
países fuera de la región.
La nueva moneda podría utilizarse tanto para
el comercio como para los flujos financieros
entre países de la región.
” Fernando Haddad y Gabriel Galípolo en
mayo de este año.)
Y ahora que el mismo Lula da Silva ha mencionado
este tema, integrándose como parte de su
campaña presidencial:
o
C6:(“Si Dios quiere vamos a crear una moneda
en América Látina porque no nos podemos
quedar dependiendo del dólar” Luiz Inácio
Lula da Silva)
En principio, el SUR es algo más complejo
que el Peso Real, pero la principal diferencia
es que ahora la Argentina ya no es aquella
soñadora nación de 2019.
Este año el peso argentino es una de las
monedas que más se está devaluando en todo
el mundo, con una inflación esperada en 2022
cercana al 100%.
Y quizás por eso en julio de este año, el
entonces Ministro argentino de Desarrollo
Productivo, mencionó esto:
C7: ("Hablé más de una hora con el ministro
Guedes y un punto central de la conversación
fue la actualización de las transacciones
con monedas locales” Daniel Scioli, 14 de
julio de 2022)
Y es que, amigos, amigas, las reservas del
Banco Central Argentino se encuentran completamente
diezmadas, por lo que, con tal de no usar
dólares, los funcionarios de la Casa Rosada
están dispuestos a echarse en brazos de cualquier
otra alternativa
N4(25 de septiembre del 2022: Diputados debaten
la posibilidad de alcanzar una moneda única
con Brasil.
El proyecto que apoya la creación de la misma
fue presentado por la oposición, pero cuenta
con el beneplácito del oficialismo.
Parlamentario.com)
Claro que este no parece el mejor de los contextos
para diseñar un programa tan serio como lo
es una unificación monetaria.
Así que, lo siento, pero por mucho que Argentina
quiera, lo normal es que Brasil por ahora
quiera echar el freno.
T6 (CONSTRUYENDO LA CASA POR EL TEJADO)
Amigos, amigas, América Latina es una región
socialmente muy homogénea, pero con escasos
niveles de consenso, constituciones que cambian
cada dos por tres y gobiernos que suelen pender
de un hilo.
Y eso, eso complica mucho una idea, la de
tener una moneda común, que como habéis
visto es transversal a la izquierda y a la
derecha.
Ahora bien, aquí hay que tener algo en cuenta:
los países estabilizan sus economías para
llevar a cabo una unificación monetaria,
no unifican sus monedas para estabilizar sus
economías.
Qué la verdad, parece que es lo que esperan
la mayoría de líderes regionales.
Es decir, en América Latina quien defiende
una moneda común parece defenderla para enfrentarse
a problemas estructurales como la inflación
crónica.
Y eso es lo mismo que empezar la casa por
el tejado.
Tener una moneda común, como ya vimos en
VisualEconomik con el caso del dólar, puede
facilitar tener una tasa de inflación baja,
tasas de crecimiento positivas y disminuir
la incertidumbre.
Puede facilitar la prosperidad pero no garantizarla.
Y una moneda común que se pusiera en marcha
con tantos desequilibrios podría nacer condenada
al fracaso de antemano.
Eso sí, si se fijaran normas claras, una
autoridad monetaria completamente independiente
y la política monetaria se ciñera al control
de precios, entonces, al menos las tasas de
inflación altas podrían quedar erradicada
del continente.
Y tanto los ahorradores e inversores ganarían
mucha seguridad jurídica.
Pero, claro, sin poder meter mano, ¿Cuántos
países se mantendrían fieles a esta moneda?
Pero, por poner una nota positiva: según
un estudio publicado en febrero de 2022 por
el Instituto para la Integración de América
Latina y el Caribe del Banco Interamericano
de Desarrollo, 7 de cada 10 ciudadanos latinoamericanos
dicen estar a favor de que sus países se
integren más.
Así que quién sabe, puede que todo este
deseo de crear una moneda común termine haciéndose
realidad [Y si no, bueno, siempre estará
el dólar]
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Creés que realmente veremos una moneda
común en América Latina?
¿Podrían gobiernos como el argentino superar
su adicción al banco central?
¿Estarían dispuestos los políticos a renunciar
por completo al control de la política monetaria?
¿Te parece que Brasil podrá liderar un proyecto
de esta clase en el corto plazo?
Dejadnos por aquí abajo vuestros comentarios
y abramos debate.
Por supuesto si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like y suscribirte
a VisualPolitik.
Y échale también un vistazo a nuestro canal
hermano VisualEconomik.
Muchas gracias una vez más por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.